hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here with a weight again say
hello Wade hello
not like that tape better oh hello they
Nemer
say it with hebrew yeah go ahead that's
not what I said but yeah go for it man
hello that's very offensive Wade how
dare you I've got Jewish blood in me I'm
allowed to be offensive I made I made a
Jewish name joke in the one that no one
else D cuz it screwed up but yeah it was
there well now that I stay like that it
just sounds really fun it wasn't
offensive everybody wasn't right Wade
sound sofa no no I swear to god it was
an offense if I love the Jews I mean I'm
just saying yeah okay there go all of
our neo-nazi viewers that's a bad joke
ha ha ha
there you know with all the viewers that
you have especially I have we probably
have some of like every possible thought
process yeah you're probably not wrong
let me just say in advance as we keep
digging our own graves
how many more ethnic groups can we make
fun of thank you first rate more than
one I haven't been doing it for a minute
how many people can we offend as fast as
we can Oh probably a lot haha well go
I'm waiting I'm waiting offend me I'm
not I'm not doing this this is you I'm
not doing anything what are you talking
about I'm not offending anybody no are
you sure about that
I try to you should have a nice guide
are you really I have evidence to the
contrary on that claim what that's your
brilliant not a nice guy I can't do it
at all there's a zombie trapped in my
wood that is a funny statement comical
and humorous in every way yeah except
for the the real way ok yeah that
wouldn't be fun in any way yeah oh don't
think yeah
remember this is a kid show where all
your dirty thoughts that you're getting
please put those aside
but if a zombie try to burst through my
floor wouldn't be pleasant oh I get it
that could still be misconstrued as
dirty pretty much everything that we're
saying that one everything we
can be misconstrued as dirty okay I dug
a pretty deep hole I leave this place
now yeah we'll leave it and we'll come
back because this is kind of our home
away from home we we we know this oh
calling me who how are you
from ones from Kalamazoo I guess it'd be
this times it's not me I don't know
yeah I can't who the hell will be
calling me from Kalamazoo I have no idea
oh we weren't live streaming this were
we and I didn't say my telephone number
like right on I did i sorry that one's
alright well there's a whole bunch of
ladies um bees like right here why why
are there all believe you I'm bad lady
Oh
copyright female they say who's fluffy
now no I didn't why do you keep
mistaking what I say I don't know
probably the stairs flower man
what would you say exactly huh
what now you're getting it all right it
is dingy like wood through your bud oh
the things are saying me laughs honestly
did not mean for that to sound like that
you grabbed my wood through my butt eh
well it's like you can't dig yourself
out of that one yeah the sound that we
made walking through that pile did you
hear that
what no I didn't it was like when I was
Doody in I didn't hear what I walked
through the second time as long as we do
anything you're a lying liar you lie huh
you're a liar okay
listen to my video when I post okay okay
okay we don't have time we got to go up
to the suburban area and grab what we
can and then come back before dusk can
we do this badly can we do that while we
tell jokes because if we do both at the
same time it will save a lot of time
fartknocker
all right let's keep going fartknocker
really that's the best joke you got ah
channeling my inner Terrance and Phillip
oh I gotcha well I'd like to think that
we're just a bit above Terrance and
Phillip have you watched us
glad you believe your farted in my face
hey exactly is that what we do is that
what we have devolved to go Bowlin
because we're less mature yes well you
you're saying we're worse than Terrance
and Phillip is that what you're saying
in a better sort of way in a better sort
of way how is that even in a better
sword away because it's not worse in the
fact that it's better whoa
one of those long wait a minute knock
table second you're saying that we can
be better by being worse good yes I know
about that oh I could robot leader
murder God dead isn't it Geico that does
the ones like the kids uh whoa wait what
the commercials no I mean what I have no
idea what you're talking about
they're like less is better let's bear
are you competing have you not seen any
of the commercials where there's the
Geico guy whatever sitting around the
Copa kid what's Geico you never mind
what are you talking about man not
everybody in the comments do you know
what he's talking about
the commercial insurance company that
has all the little kids like rim circle
and one of the kids always says
something and like the other kids like
like that what there's the one with the
cutest kid oh my god no continue please
tell your story no seriously what are
you talking about yeah dog house I'm in
the dog
hey it seemed to be having fun over
there we have fun on this game we have
fun don't we have fun wait oh yeah with
a blast we have a blast
oh got a horse jokes to tell Oh what
were we talking about I don't even know
we're talking about some Geico or
whatever you were dad only their shirts
come here so there's like I don't
remember the gist of it but the end
she's the guys like are you competing
for cutest kid right now and she's like
yes he's like what place are you and she
goes kindergarten that's like that's
adorable that's the end of the
commercial
oh I don't know what you're talking
about you guys
seen it have they steam yeah but you
don't watch no television I don't want
elleven I really don't I don't either
that's this dog a bow oh I got it right
in the face like good isn't a face to go
I owned it right in the furs okay anyway
what problem
what okay you scream I've ever had my
entire life might have been that might
have been your girliest grieve ever that
was delightful I am so glad I was here
for that I was just getting ready to
burp and I had to scream and it came out
just like that
only worse I've had some pretty
high-pitched screams in my day but none
Glenn Hodge and I gotta get my
inventories way too full I got too many
sticks I've got too much junk I've got
feathers I've got tin cans that I don't
know what they do yeah it's not good in
this building I've got a pump shotgun
but I don't need it so I don't know I
don't know what's going on here oh I'm
not having a good time in this house
you're not having a swell evening I'm
not having a swell evening a soupy Dobby
zubeidaa be doin the space worthy
projectile hahahaha Bob Chupacabra damn
no don't start that again
that's an inside joke between me and way
that we can't do here and that's so
depressing
yeah oh by the way you all probably know
what song I'm talkin about
look up the lyrics to that song someone
someone told me about that I forget who
told me that I think I like someone told
me in LA might've been hearing credit
right now forty buddy don't know who was
what you see you're giving them credit
you just don't know their name I don't
know their name you know who you are if
you're watching this but you're prolly
not watching it because I believe it was
either egoraptor or Barry or someone who
said that to me this is your shoutout
anonymous yeah whoever you are that told
me that that those lyrics are really
really depressing
yeah was it no was it it was a stint ago
no was it I don't know well whoever you
are I obviously don't care hahahaha you
on this show well yeah when I meet you
better Bret next show I think it might
have been Daniel from cyndago I'm not
sure all right cleared out this house
I'm leaving this house I'm finding just
water I'm not finding anything like I
was really hoping you would find a bunch
of food
seeds I found a little bit of food I got
potato seeds hmm we can't grow a farm
not our users though I'm went into this
brick house brick house has to be pretty
sturdy raise your bragging row we're
building building - Marty Marty it's
very sturdy and comfy ha ha ha ha
really now tell me more building did
Matty mightier Oh what the hell Oh lamb
ration why doesn't lamb ration staff
Mason you had a lamb wrap my guy oh I'm
not gonna die hang on crisis nearly
averted it's uh 3 o'clock in the
afternoon by the way weird okay we
should probably do something about that
there wait I'm in the brick house like
right behind you we're not gonna survive
in the brick house we're going back to
our house so I can keep digging
overnight oh boy okay
we got plenty of time but we should
probably start making our way back soon
all right let me eat some food here get
some nice little yummies in my tummy's
mmm yummies in your tummy Jay tell me
more about the yummy junior kill me I
need yummies in my tummy so I can get by
I didn't mean to rap but I'm a pretty
fly guy whoa keep going there wait I
think you discovered a new talent yeah
did you went to Milford did you hear
whenever I am was in Concert Choir I had
to do a rap solo no I didn't hear that
at all tell me more I I stole a piece of
candy from a friend of ours who had just
tried out for concert choir because he
had actually stolen a piece of like food
from my lunch or some point I thought
this was your rap I was like this is an
awful rap I'm like oh okay this actual
story okay we got to start making our
way back like now now now don't blow
away zombies
stop blowing the zombies and tell your
story on the run we scrap metal
tell me your story on the run but
alright so I stole candy from this guy
who had stolen food from my lunch but it
just so happened that the lady the
teacher who gave it to him was in charge
of Concert Choir ah only got candy if
you tried out for Concert Choir okay so
she made me try out for Concert Choir of
which of course I say like jingle bells
I was like there's no way I'm gonna get
in and I got in Oh
for you they pretty much took every or
everyone so what I did with my entire
time in there was basically make a
mockery didn't want to be there I mean I
was a terrible singer but I don't like
singing in public I guess yeah so I made
fun of this one song it just happened to
be happy Kwanzaa ah because in the very
middle there was some weird little like
solar where the guy wasn't even singing
but it wasn't really rapping he was just
kind of like talking okay so I made a
rap out of it as a joke and the teacher
actually made me do that for the song
when we performed it lie okay and I had
a pic afro at the time yeah you did
everyone knows about your big afro okay
so everyone all watching out there
you're in for a treat because you're
going to hear wade rap take it away Wade
what am I supposed to be rapping your
song that you were just talking about
you can tell that whole story and not
rap the rap okay well to end the story
before I give you the rap we basically
sang our songs in front of a bunch of
retirement homes and with my big afro my
rap solo they did not take too kindly to
me well let's sing it I want to know
what it is everyone want everyone chant
in the comment Wade rap why that doesn't
it needs to be three things ah you know
this video will be over with by the time
they comment Wade can't rap Wade can't
rap everybody sing it was share with me
Wade can't rap
Wade can't rap way can't rap
oh yeah rap okay do you get your butt
out of my way do it you could have gone
all my delightful bot that you love do
you lock this Bart
haha I forgot about the view like you
like this Bart do you like this bond
Wade you're actually bent over and
showing off your chest now
no I'm showing it to the audience from
my point of view look okay that's weird
a bit bit improve patch cap wrap Wade
boom back up just got him straight about
who map went like beavis Kakha boo boo
tap out above your boobs ba ba ba boo
boo bop house it's a part of the year
that you don't want to mix like each
gift but the harder you wish to suicide
uh principle and tell me what anything
you Oh
was it how was it how was it yeah go
everybody ladies and gentlemen that was
Wade's rap well done wages and only ever
attempt at the hip hop the hip hop I
don't think the hip hop is the same as
the rap it isn't no the rap the rap was
a wrestler he was in the WWF before it
kept up with the rock no that was the
rap and then the rap went on to make
movies
then came the rock the rock the rapid
came before the rock uh then the roll
came after but he didn't come like any
what's came before the chicken uh I
believe it was the prehistoric ancestor
do the chicken the teraflops order are
the pips the what the smelly armpits yes
the teraflop de rasa pits teraflop the
Raza pit the sorban Gabon we're not
doing anything yes this is the first
time we've actually stopped not doing
anything anyway we're all better
we're all at a time oh don't get to work
yeah we're out of time I'll get to work
on what we're gonna do is we're gonna
dick around during the night and then we
will come back when it's done so you
guys don't have to sit through I know
what we do is we just keep talking like
this but we want to be able to actually
do stuff while we talk so that's where
we're gonna stay before so anyway we're
gonna be in complete silence for the
next five minutes all right thank you
all so much for watching thank you wait
for joining me welcome that's all you
got to say really that's all you get I
thought we were sitting silence I was
trying to get it started fine I hope you
all have a lovely evening while I have
to sit here with waiting yeah
see you in the next video bye
uh a man again
Oh No
okay all right we were really gonna sit
in silence Wade oh okay if we can if you
want geez you go not very good okay so
you sort of work on the mind yeah I'm
just gonna keep digging down I don't
know if you make this big enough make
sure you keep supports yeah cuz it will
collapse on you I've been told oh and
there's iron or something up here you
didn't break oh really
yeah right here in the middle oh I
didn't even know what that was yeah cool
aw damn there's one I'm standing on
right here two behind you really and man
I've just been passing over these things
no joke iron ore what is it can you just
like break it down with like yeah you
just literally putting your inventory
right now oh nine iron ingots holy hell
yeah there's another one up there on the
stair hot damn I'm getting this one
right here then there's like potassium
nitrate right here I don't know what
that does oh it's used for farming and
making bullets okay yeah potassium
nitrate that's like fertilizer yep cool
well this is gonna turn out well
what is this Cole I got cold ice nice -
gotten lumps of coal ash all that grass
that presents for Christmas Santa
Clauses got some coal for your buck
recording or still being insulting
pressure chicken Bund over there weighty
post ha ha ha you're actually doing it
yeah Santa
mrs. Santa Claus was here only I have
mrs. Santa Claus you sounds just like
Santa Claus oh all right for your Cole
reward
hey hey no no like just just kind of it
no no please have been safe do not do oh
well here comes company no come and
knock on our door you don't know what
Leave It to Beaver is though I'd really
don't I don't know what leaf de Vera's
wow that's like a really famous sitcom
what is it I think I've heard the famous
did Kyle that stereotypical the 1950s
we're like the husband works the wife
stays home and cleans
Cook's okay like the kids response is
always like ah gee whiz pop uh yeah I
have no idea we're talking about all you
got a like YouTube like an episode of
that or something just cuz it's it's so
stereotypical like it's the
stereotypical sitcom from the 50s I'm
usually pretty knowledgeable though they
store stuff about that's why I thought
you were joking when you said you didn't
know yeah I'm totally blanking on that
one I really don't know yeah it's like a
really famous sitcom I've heard the name
I just don't know anything about it like
I ever see
maybe I'm just mixing up with like
beavis and butt-head or some like I
don't know Butthead I don't know either
way I probably look horrible in the eyes
of the viewers haha then again when
don't I hahahaha that's the real joke oh
we gonna be like that wait I meant that
nicest way you did not you lie yeah
maybe what you laugh like that I talk
like that
wait my Bible zooms King I didn't King I
thought we were representative democracy
the power supply the people who's just a
boy earlier I love that show that movie
yeah I watched it like 10 million times
I haven't watched it in a while I
thought see in a long time when I was in
a marching band it was like it was like
the movie that they'd always show us we
were making her way for long trips or
something I got real sick of it after a
while but you know it's a good show Oh
zombies getting up upstairs oh no fair
no really yeah don't know how Stan or
they were up here didn't you break down
the door or something here I got stoned
no no no no no no no no no oh give it I
am near Earth what hey they broke right
through the stone how'd they do that I
do not know I thought stone was like
strong it's supposed to be it just broke
right through it this guy wants
something
it's dead Oh nurse thank you thank you
wait um yeah yeah yeah yeah we should
get back downstairs
why oh yeah we should probably get back
downstairs
you want me to block off the upstairs
with stone uh no just well it doesn't
matter
I mean I'm picked through it with the
pickaxe ahead good I mean we got tons of
uh iron to work with so we should be
fine yeah we should be fine all right
it's almost morning anyway yeah
study know when you're ready where will
we start our farm cuz I want to do that
um we'll probably have to build like a
separate well we're gonna do it
underground or else we can do it like an
another elevated structure that will
build out of the stone that you're
harvesting we need dirt for that right
yes wanting to harvest some dirt for
that now is it like can we build in any
biome honestly I've never gotten to the
point of having a farm before the beta's
reset I got lead or it turns into lead
ingots yeah I don't know 100% what
that's used for either we're getting
close to the point where like I haven't
gotten that much further
oh it's used for bullets okay yeah I
figured lead and potassium are for
bullets I just don't know exactly how
the crafting works for that okay I
accidentally dumped my dirt a while back
I don't know where I put it
so you may have to go out and get more
dirt that's fun okay either way yeah
this is actually turning out pretty well
all the working on the mine I'm actually
getting some good stuff out of it
oh yeah we're actually set up pretty
well all right yeah that's it we are